80,000 cases in the u.s. 85,000 cases
yeah what does New York have right now
New York leading the pack n why see 37
thousand cases 387 deaths in the state
of New York ah you know it's interesting
man it's a real reset for anybody who's
young if you're under 25 it's time to
move back home
if you can move back home listen don't
don't be upset don't think it's a
failure but if you if it's at all
possible for you to go back home for 12
to 24 months and save [ __ ] money
there's no shame in it
this is a reset I can't go home my
mother's in a mental institution and my
father and his wife lived together
I can't there is no home for me to go
and I'm 35 that's also you can't go home
when you're 35 that's it you're in your
mid-30s you the home you go in you're 35
is your death eventually you're closer
to that then the age when you can just
walk you know go home which is why in
retrospect what a great time
9/11 was it was just such a fun [ __ ]
time 9/11 Wow just growing up being
young you know is it gonna be anthrax
it's gonna be smallpox what's gonna get
us bioterror nothing happened there were
no additional attacks you know you know
what's great about 9/11 everything made
you a hero
going out and getting drunk maybe a hero
because if you didn't go out and get
drunk the terrorists one right oh so
good if you didn't go out and get drunk
and eat a sandwich at 2:00 a.m. the
terrorists one do you want the
terrorists to win no so you go live your
life remember President Bush he said
what can Americans do he said go
shopping go shopping because that's what
we are we got to lean in a little bit to
that we are demons from hell
that's really what we are we're not a
good country of good people that idea
to be smashed let's lean in its I get it
when bushes like go shopping he's not
wrong he's like what are you guys gonna
do anyway what are you gonna do what are
you gonna do to grief counseling shut
the [ __ ] what are you gonna what are you
gonna volunteer your time to talk to
people do grief counseling no go and buy
a dress go get a car and drive it real
fast fatty go get a panini press go get
a waffle iron I mean that's what we do
we shop or the terrorists win we get
drunk or the terrorists win that was a
great thing about 9/11 you were it was
your patriotic duty to consume to
consume to go out and gorge yourself
with food and wine and booze do shots
with your friends and get [ __ ] up on
the weekends because this is America and
that's how we roll and el shamah bin
Laden will never take that away from us
he'll never take away our ability to go
out to bars and get [ __ ] up with money
that we stole from our parents one way
or the other sometimes it was hard
stealing there's a little money on a
mantle it's mine sometimes you go right
into the pocketbook right into the purse
take a little bit off the top go right
in there and grab a couple of 20s 50 we
got undred gotta be a good night gotta
be a good night hope she doesn't notice
she's out of you a lot of people in Long
Island stole klepto maniacs they steal
money I love it I would take money every
now and then I was a junk box druggie
some people did it sober that's funny to
me hilarious I mean I know people were
stone-cold sober stealing from their
families great no excuse stealing
stealing clothes you know something very
deeply wrong with the area that I come
from it's a sickness worse than Corona
it's worse than kovat it's a hundred
percent rate of being a piece of [ __ ]
that's the statistic you go up in Long
Island yeah full of malls you get a job
because your mother's friend Deb know
someone at the Rec Center you just sit
there in a chair and watch people almost
drown in the pool
life is a meaningless waste of time
don't kid yourself and don't kid
yourself I don't think much will change
in this country to this upend I mean I
thought that it would and my people are
gonna start getting serious they'll move
out to the suburbs are gonna want kids
you can want to the garage you know they
want real SH I don't know I don't know
it would be great if that [ __ ] ends if
you're a [ __ ] one-man show is over if
you realize that you want to get you
know something real in your life
tangible property family you're not just
gonna waltz around being a dilettante
pretending to be an artist wasting your
own time and everybody else's you know
your could get dangerous again the
economy could get bad moving to a city
like that could be a real risk the fun
might be over you better really [ __ ]
want it you better really want it if you
gave you could get a knife to your
throat on the a train you better really
want to be [ __ ] funny and interesting
you better really want otherwise the
pull of the traditional life the life
that many of you should be living the
traditional life that but it's gonna be
it's gonna be very strong after this
pandemic my prediction could be wrong is
that the pull of that tradition is gonna
come back suburbs back I want space I
want property I want a house how many
people are quarantine in a box right now
going no more yeah I want out I want to
I want something real I want to love
someone I want them to love me
I want real responsibilities I don't
want to host affair with her friends and
people trying to step on my neck to get
ahead I want to get the [ __ ] out of
these cities like New York and LA and go
people like me are gonna stay but we
should stay because we're we're good at
what we do
wait and you know I'm talking to if
you're sitting out there and you listen
to this and you're like are you talking
to me yeah yeah yeah if you even think
like that I'm talking to you you should
be sitting there gonna [ __ ] this fat
[ __ ] I'd do it better than him and then
you got a shot if you're sitting there
god [ __ ] this guy I could do that show
better
he's what his Netflix is whatever
everybody sweats this guy but [ __ ] him
who cares I would do it better oh I'm
mega begun
good that now I respect you you little
demon but you'll still fail cuz life's a
[ __ ] so don't get too high on your high
horse